But I've got a challenge for all the guys, because men love challenges.
I challenge you to see if you can use the same qualities...
...that you feel make you a man to go deeper into yourself,...
Your strength, your bravery, your toughness.
Can we redefine what those mean and use them to explore our hearts?
Are you brave enough to be vulnerable?
To reach out to another man when you need help?
To dive headfirst into your shame?
Are you strong enough to be sensitive,...
...to cry whether you are hurting or you're happy,...
...even if it makes you look weak?
Are you confident enough to listen to the women in your life,...
...to hear their ideas and their solutions?
To hold their anguish and actually believe them,...
...even if what they're saying is against you?
And will you be man enough to stand up to other men when you hear "locker-room talk"?
When you hear stories of sexual harassment?
Will you actually stand up and do something...
...so that one day we don't have to live in a world...
...where a woman has to risk everything...
...and come forward to say the words, "Me too"?